hello and welcome to the shiki-san show
in this video I'll provide an
introduction to the gut microbiome
because I think in the next couple of
videos I'm going to fake it a little bit
on this because there's some really
interesting research in this area so the
aim of this video then is just to find a
general overview as to what is the gut
microbiome and and why you should care
so you will learn about how the
microbiome can fluctuate by a variety of
different factors and then we'll also
take a little look at some companies
that offer services to look at your gut
microbiome so you firstly then what is
the gut microbiome well here comes the
scary facts we are not alone in our
bodies in fact we are also containing
trillions of microorganisms so this
doesn't just include bacteria but it
also includes viruses and fungi as well
and so collectively this is referred to
as the microbiome however most of the
current research is more focused on the
bacterial species so I'll kind of fix on
that as well and there are hundreds of
this thing it's bacterial species within
the gods and so they can be good and bad
so some of them are beneficial but some
of them are pathogenic and understanding
the differences between them is what's
really interesting and so these these
microbes then they're not just
passengers within the body they also
play active roles in a variety of
different processes and are actually
more like team players within our bodies
and so there's evidence now that links
the microbiome to metabolism also to
immunity and there's also some evidence
about it related to neuronal development
as well so it's a really interesting
topic I'm so related to this obviously
defects metabolism immunity and neuronal
development are also linked to disease
and so the microbiome is also related to
the Seas and there's now lots of
evidence linking the microbiome
composition to diseases such as
Alzheimer's autism depression autoimmune
diseases such as multiple sclerosis and
also cancer and so I'm currently
planning to go into little bit more
detail into these different associations
within the next upcoming videos so yeah
look forward about
so that the way that we treat disease
through drugs and medicines is also you
tightly associated with microbiome
because they can also influence the
metabolism of face drugs and affect how
these drugs are acting on your body but
on the flip side as will come to near
the end of the video we could also
potentially use this understanding of
the microbiome to target the microbiome
itself as a therapeutic and so we've now
looked at what the gut microbiome is and
the key point to take away is that the
gut microbiome isn't Mike on genetics
where it's fixed I've got Mike O'Brien
it's very dynamic and the composition
can change and so as I've already
mentioned there are a variety of
different factors that can influence the
composition of your guts microbiome so
there's some Crees things like your age
possibly your sex definitely your diet
and also your geographical location and
you can even artificially alter your
microbiome through transplants I mean
not personal you can just see that I
mean like there's research into this and
they've done like rats and mice so how
does your microbiome change as you age
well I came across a really good graph
that I found in a recent nature a few
paper and so I'll put the link for that
paper in the description and I'll try
and recapitulate it here so if we track
the relative abundance of some arbitrary
bacterial species that you don't need to
worry about at the moment and look at
the relative abundance for our age we
can see that it's altering so what
happens then as we age so if you first
look at infancy what happens during
infancy is that during breastfeeding
there's human milk lega saccharides and
they participates in the Malaysian of
the microbiota in this early stage of
life and then as in infancy you progress
to eating solid foods that's also
followed by an increase in bacterial
richness so then if we look at
adulthoods
we can see that generally it seems
pretty stable but then there's these
fluctuations that occur on a daily scale
so obviously the circadian rhythm and
you're feeding fasting cycles will also
have short-term influences on the
microbiome composition
and also what you're eating is very
important so for example if you have
let's say a high-protein diet you will
see a bias in the composition towards a
certain population of bacterial species
that favor that diet and so what the
healthy diet for you is thought now to
be closely linked to your microbiome
composition and given that the
microbiome influences metabolism
influences immunity and neural
development can you target your diet too
you know optimize your microbiome and
optimize your health and well I need to
look more into this myself but I think
the general consensus is that the more
diverse your microbiome is the better
but I mean I'm going to look into rest
more covetous and way more detail and
the next couple of videos and then when
you look at late life from current
observations there appears to be a
decline in the richness of the
microbiome and that's generally thought
to be associated with a reduced free
diversity at the stage of life and so
again as there ways that you could
increase its diversity to prevent aging
to optimize the health of the older
population okay so now let's delve into
a bit deeper into the diet and the
saying you are what you eat which I
remember hearing us are kids and
thinking was quite funny but there's a
lot of truth in it and what you eat
definitely does influence your
microbiome composition and so we already
know that moving to solid food and
infancy increases the richness and also
we know that there's a lot of evidence
that dietary fiber it's you know like
the food for the microbiome and so when
it's fermented by the microbiome one of
the products are these short chain fatty
acids and the interesting evidence is
that's been linked with the activity
levels of t-cells which are linked to
your immunity and gave back to my
neutral point of how the microbiome and
its byproducts are so associated with
the sea States and let food be thy
medicine
kind of like the best way to represent
our current understanding of the
microbiome with disease and a good study
that kind of illustrates my point is
this cell host and microbe paper that I
discussed previously that looked at how
the diet strongly affects the gut
microbiome position and in particular
how that affects the the barrier between
the colon and human cells which is the
barrier that separates the gut
microbiome from ourselves and so mice
that were on a western-style diet had
increased permeability of this barrier
which is bad and it could increase
inflammation in the body whereas when
they prevented this by transplanting a
specific type of microbiota they kind of
reversed this permeability and that is a
good thing but that's not good for
humans yet and just to mention another
study briefly there was a study that
looked at how partly the effects of
taking metformin as a treatment for type
2 diabetes is also partially mediated by
the gut microbiota and say what they did
in this study which I'll link down below
in the description is they assessed the
stool sample of 22 patients that had
type 2 diabetes and they had been a
metformin for three days and even within
that short time scale they saw changes
in the composition of the microbiota and
in particular they saw a decrease in
this bacterial species and an increase
in the levels of bile acids so given
that composition is so important how can
you actually assess your own microbiome
composition well I can doing some
research and there's quite big companies
that seem to offer personalized testing
of your microbiome and then they provide
feedback on to what specific foods you
shouldn't shouldn't eat and so when I
came across was volume and so what you
do is you order one of their kits and
then you provide them with a pea-sized
sample of your stool and you send it
back to the lab they then using
transcript a note so looking at the RNA
in your stool sample and then combining
that with artificial intelligence
they come up with
plan of the diet and the fields that you
should engine avoid and according to
their website
it's the only company currently able to
identify and quantify the gut microbiota
to salmon what these live organisms are
producing and present personalized diet
and nutrition advice so I mean I don't
know how good these companies are at the
moment I wouldn't trust them yet one
because there's still so much research
to do and to understand and also
especially the artificial intelligence
those kind of software's will improve as
you get more data but there are other
companies as well they're offering the
same thing not just by him so there's
you biome day - and Atlas BioMed's and
so I reckon as well that's probably
going to be even more companies that
start offering these kind of services
but yeah as I said I mean there isn't
none of them can provide a complete
picture of your microbiome it's way too
complicated to be able to do that but I
guess I think it's cool that there are
companies that are offering stuff like
this because I think is really
interesting as I have this kind of
information so on the flip side there
are also quite a few research companies
that are doing research into the
microbiome itself and how they can use
be used for drug treatments so one is
pure tech health and they are answering
the questions what if we could treat
immune and infectious disease by
mimicking the way in which the gut
microbiota maintains a healthy immune
system in humans so that's can we target
the microbiome to benefit and treat
diseases so as I said this has just been
a brief intro to what is the microbiome
and why it is important to understand it
but I think there's you know a lot of
excitement in this area and there's a
lot of really interesting research to
come from it so I think the gut
microbiome is very cool so as always
thanks for listening